for months it looked like this was
former Vice President Joe Biden's race
to lose and so far he has been losing
now the unexpected frontrunner a
self-declared socialist senator Bernie
Sanders getting the most votes in Iowa
New Hampshire and Nevada we have now one
caucus following him another unexpected
leader former small town mayor Pete Buda
judge with Biden trailing third this is
a race that will decide the direction of
the Democratic Party there are the
moderates Biden Buda judge senator Amy
Klobuchar
and billionaires Tom Steyer and former
Mayor Mike Bloomberg and the outlier
congresswoman Tulsi Gabbard versus the
progressives Sanders and senator
Elizabeth Warren the biggest divide
Healthcare it's the second most
important issue for Democratic voters
the moderates want more people to be
able to join the government health
insurance program the progressives want
everyone enrolled in a government
program with private insurance
eliminated
that's something the majority of
Democrats say they want according to
polls but that isn't true for
independents or Republicans and that
could complicate what the vast majority
of Democrats say is their top priority
electability without a doubt that's my
number one I want Trump and that is the
biggest argument against senator Sanders
that he can't beat Trump I think we
could win the Democratic nomination
[Applause]
and I'm absolutely certain we're gonna
defeat Donald Trump but if he's the
nominee
Jocelin Kylie at the Pew Research Center
says his health care plan could be an
issue both the public option approach
and the medicare-for-all
approach are distinctly different than
the Republican policies of about
healthcare and Democrats across the
board are likely to favor both of those
well Republicans across the board are
much less likely to favor either
Medicare for all or a public option
Democrats are deciding with this vote if
promising big changes is the best chance
they have to change who lives in the
White House patty called Haman al
Jazeera Washington